I loved your book you know I did I
thought your book was fabulous it just
came out in paperback I'll give you a
plug you talked about your history you
talked about your experience with
basketball you personally when you
played when you were in high school and
then you got a break in college this guy
uh I don't even know who he is I've
never heard of him before Jason Whitlock
I don't know him he basically went on
and said oh Stephen A Smith's lying
lying right no evidence that you're
lying and it's shitty like you don't
want to be involved in that you're like
[__] this guy you know but you came out
and made a statement well I had to I had
to I had to um listen I I I promised uh
my bosses Howard I promised my family I
even promised my pastor literally
beforehand this is what I'm going to do
I've never done it before in my
professional career and I will never do
it again but this one time I'm going to
make this exception and I'm going to ask
y'all to live with it cuz it's not what
I do um and without getting into it and
I'll never mention his name again and
I'll never talk about him again what I
will do is
explain why I did what I
did I have been attacked for 12 straight
years I've never by this guy yes I've
never said a word not even his name he
has attacked me he has attacked numerous
friends and contemporaries in this
business personal
attacks
Relentless
nonstop he attacked networks he's
attacked
employers he's attacked colleagues he's
attacked me and so I said look at some
point in
time I am Stephen A and I have a
bullhorn that most people in this
industry don't have on behalf of me and
all of the folks every black
person that I know in this
industry thanked me for what I did
because it has been that Relentless and
unabated I mean you know when you have
somebody that's willing to do that it's
just a moment that lives in time where
you want to do something that says this
is who you are let everybody know what
my perspective is now I move on with my
life attacking the big guy which is you
you know you've you've clawed your way
to the top nobody gave you anything damn
right nobody handed you anything damn
right and then suddenly you realize
what's going on the game is hey I'm
being attacked I'm being accused of [__]
that that there's no proof of I have
friends I have teammates uh high school
colleges go to the hospital look up
their records uh look at teachers
professors coaches Etc my book that I
wrote Let's be very very clear about
this Simon and Schuster has editors one
is Amy Bell another guy in his imprint
is Charles suit ask him you understand
what I'm saying ask ran McDonald a dear
friend of mine who's been in my life and
is still in my life and a part of my
business and a close Confidant of mine
ask my sisters ask my colleagues ask the
folks that on NBA um NBA shoot around
which is now NBA Countdown on ESPN well
in between when we're watching the games
I was writing my book all right not just
at home but in the office I mean the
evidence is there and and and let me be
very very clear about
something how can I put this in a in the
most decent but direct manner
possible as I said in my book my mother
said it
best it's a hell of a lot
easier to force people to live with your
truth than it is for you to live with
your lives nobody's important enough to
be lying to Howard and they just not you
I mean it's I mean I mean life is listen
I've got one of listen nothing's perfect
but I have one of the best jobs in
America okay I work for one of the of
the best companies and some of the best
bosses on this planet I'm making good
money okay life is kind of good I don't
why do I need to write a book okay where
are are you kidding
me